These rich people, you know, don't you get
sick and tired of them.
All they care about is money!
They're such greedy people.
Right?
You know, it's crazy all this stuff I'm telling
you, I grew up believing this.
I literally grew up despising rich people.
I had certain relatives, when we grew up in
Tehran, Iran, we were a low-income family,
so I never lived in a house.
Never.
I never lived in a house.
We never had a back yard, it was always an
apartment.
And so we came to the States, parents get
a divorce.
I joined the Army and got out, and all of
a sudden, I read a quote in book I read, when
I was at Bally Total Fitness, this guy recommends
me this book, and the quote is, "If you're
born poor, it's not your fault.
But if you die poor, it's your fault.
By Bill Gates.
I said, "Wait a minute.
What do you mean if I'm born poor, it's not
my fault, but if I die poor, it's my fault.
You're trying to say if I don't die rich,
it's my fault, and it's all because of me?
Yes!
Why?
Because you control your choices.
Your friendships, your association with what
you feed your mind, what you read, how much
T.V.
you watch, how hard you work, how much you're
improving, what industry.
These are all your choices.
You have your choices.
But Pat, I live in a different country.
But you have a choice to live there or not,
or leave to another country.
But Pat, you don't understand.
. . You have choices.
And when that got into my brain, I realized
one thing.
I had a choice to think all rich people were
greedy and bad people.
And you and I will never become what we hate.
And I couldn't stand rich people.
And I had to shift that mind.
And let me tell you, it's not easy to do.
I had to shift that mindset.
When I did, and I realized all these stereotypes
and these myths, all of them, were debunked,
then I started thinking in a completely different
way.
And I'm here to tell you, my entire outcome
of this entire video is for you, by the time
we're done, if you don't have any problem
with rich people, then this video's just going
to validate a lot of the points that you have
for yourself, and even give you more ammunition
when you talk to other people.
But if you're somebody that grew up in a family
that didn't have a lot of money, and you have
this intuition or you have this stereotype
of how rich people are, I hope by the time
we're done you're going to think about it
differently.
Now, let's start off here.
#1:Rich people, man, they're not happy.
They're so miserable.
You know, rich people are not happy.
You think they're happy?
They're not happy.
I would hear this stuff, right?
Here's what I learned about how rich people
are.
It's not the fact that they're not happy.
They're absolutely very happy.
They're not content.
They are not content.
Let me elaborate.
So, New England Patriots just won the Super
Bowl this past week and what's the coaches
name, Belichick and Edelman are being interviewed
by Jimmy Fallon.
And Jimmy Fallon said, "Hey, Bill, when I
look at you, you just don't look like you're
happy.
Man, are you ever happy?"
He said, "I am happy.
It's just life to me is football.
And I do football."
He said, "You guys are the greatest organization,
greatest coach, all this stuff," But I'm a
football guy.
So it's always about how can we make the team
better, the offense better, the defense better,
the recruiting, the talent better.
It's always how can we make plays better.
And that comes across as not being happy.
But all it is is they're not content.
They always want to do better.
#2: Next, rich people are selfish.
It's mine!
This is mine!
That's mine.
This is mine.
That is mine.
First of all, what is wrong with us wanting
things that are ours?
See, back in the day in 1990 or 1989, Gorbachev
from Russia asked Reagan to come and visit
him.
He said, "What can I do to make our economy
be like America?"
So he goes there and says, "Listen.
Reagan looks at everybody and said, "Everybody
drives the same car.
Everybody has the same house.
Everybody eats the same food.
Everybody wears the same color underwear,
same clothes.
What's this all about?
You've got to give these guys an opportunity.
If somebody wants to work hard and drive a
nicer car, let them do it.
If somebody wants to work hard and get a bigger
house, let them do it."
And then they switched to capitalism, and
by the way, fast forward 25, 26 years later.
Today the number one country in the world
in immigration is America with 40-something
million.
You know what number two is?
Russia with 11 million.
Why?
Maybe capitalism attracted some people that
want to go out there and live in Russia.
Is it the perfect country?
Of course it's not.
Nowhere near it.
But it attracts because people can finally
say, "It's mine."
#3: Next, take advantage of people.
This actually does happen.
However, you can't do this for too long.
You cannot do this for too long.
In the world of capitalism, if you take advantage
of other people, other people have the right
to tell other people about their experience
with you.
And if it's valid, and genuine, and enough
people say it, then people say, maybe there's
some truth to it.
Now, there's one thing that you have enemies.
And there's a lot of people.
Like, for instance, right now, the most hated
person in the world today is Donald Trump.
Just six months ago, the most hated person
in the world was President Obama.
Just eight years prior to that, the most hated
person in the world was George Bush.
Just eight years.
. . it doesn't matter.
Whoever that gets the biggest limelight will
typically be the most hated person.
But, taking advantage of people?
People will eventually find out there's something
going on there.
You can't do that in business for too long.
You got to take care of your people.
If I don't take care of the best person that's
working for me, he's leaving me.
If I don't take care of the best executive,
he's leaving me.
If I don't take care of my best partners,
that are trusting us with tens of millions
of dollars, they're leaving us.
I have to understand that.
And if they don't treat us well, I'm leaving.
So there's a certain relationship that's got
to be both ways.
Right?
So this is a very, very honest formula, you
don't do well, someone's leaving.
#4: Next, money is their god.
I used to hear this.
All they care about is money.
Money is their god.
Well, first, here's what I want to do.
Why don't we break down what this whole meaning
of their god.
Is it because they spend the most time trying
to get more money?
Is that what it is?
Well then if that's the case, and if that's
our definition of what god means, we can certainly
say to most people, T.V. is their god.
We can say Netflix is their god.
We can say video games is their god, if somebody
all they want to do is play video games.
We can say porn is someone's god.
We can say sex is someone's god.
We can say a lot of things is someone's god.
So that's a lot of things that we can say.
But I can tell you one thing for a fact.
Hey, when you do make more money, and you
can do more with the money, and create more
jobs with the money, then it becomes a mathematical
formula.
You're just finding ways to do more with it.
And if you're a good person, if you're watching
this right now, let me ask you a question.
You think you're a good person?
I'm talking to you.
You, you, you.
You think you're a good person?
You think you're a good person.
Do you think you're a good person?
Really?
So if you're a good person, I have a question
for you.
Let's just say you work very hard, and in
the next five years, 10 years, all of a sudden
you're worth $100 million.
Would you do good for the world with that
$100 million?
What did you just say?
Yes?
Okay.
Now can you do better for the world with $100
million over $200,000?
Maybe you said $100 million.
Can we help you go out there and make $100
million so you can do more with that $100
million.
What's wrong with if you make more money?
Nothing wrong with that.
It's a lot better than if you just sit there
and watch video games and Netflix and T.V.
and all that other stuff.
Or even your phone and newsfeed and seeing
what other people's lives look like.
That's the point of money.
#5: Next, everybody who's a billionaire they
made their money off real estate.
It's actually not true.
A few do, but not everybody does.
#6: Next, they don't give back.
Here's an interesting stat.
According to CNBC, the average ultra-high
net worth person gives $25 million back to
charities during their lifetime.
The average high net worth, ultra-high net
worth person gives $25 million back to charities.
Here's the crazy one.
The average billionaire, during their life
time, gives $100 million back to charity.
So this whole thing about rich people don't
give money back, believe it or not, who do
you think funds most of these charities?
Who do you think funds most of these non-profits?
You think $5 donations do?
No, it's someone that comes in and write the
big check, is what they do.
#7: Next, all they do is play golf.
Some of them do.
A lot of them do.
Just recently I watched a movie, founder Ray
Kroc, I think you've got to watch it.
It's insane.
Everybody's got to watch this movie, Founder.
And there's a scene there where you know,
Ray Kroc is trying to close this deal with
this other guy to buy a couple of the franchises,
and the guy hits the ball and he's six feet
off.
And he says, "Oh, that's pretty much, it's
good, don't worry about it."
Typically it's like two feet off to say we'll
count it as a shot.
It was six, seven feet off.
He said, that's fine, it's good.
Why?
All he wanted to do was just do a business
deal.
Ray Kroc's not trying to be a professional
golfer.
He's trying to do business.
So if a wealthy person or a rich person golfs,
it's because they're trying to do business.
Some of them actually love the game.
I'm going to give that because I've golfed
with certain people that absolutely love the
game.
But not everybody.
#8: Next, yachts, homes, all this other stuff.
Yeah, sure.
Some billionaires have yachts.
Some buy it very early.
And a lot of them have private jets.
Now why do they have private jets?
Let me explain to you why they have private
jets.
The other day, I had a business meeting to
go to.
In the airport, the airline takes six hours
to find a replacement.
Then the next one takes another four hours.
I get there late to the appointment.
I couldn't do the business deal.
That could have been a good business deal,
but it never happened.
This is when the person sits there and says,
you know what?
It's time to buy a private jet.
It's $5 million, you're going to pay $100,000
a month, maybe $50,000 a month, but it's worth
the investment that you're going to make to
get there faster and get the appointments
done.
Imagine how many more places you can get to
without having to go through security, TSA,
four hours, drive, all this other stuff.
Boom, boom, you're out, you go.
And the pilot waits and you come back, quick.
So it's not necessarily about the lifestyle,
it's more about the time that I can get to
a place much faster.
#9: Next, every rich person out there's a
Republican.
Everybody!
If you're rich, they must be Republicans.
They're Trump voters.
You know, they love Romney.
They're Bush type of people.
You know, believe it or not, a lot of millionaires
are not Republicans.
There's a lot of millionaires who, I lived
in California for many years, Silicon Valley,
most of them are liberals.
They're mostly Democrats.
You go into Hollywood, there's a lot of wealthy
people there, there's a lot of Democrats.
There's a lot of liberals.
You go to New York, lots of them over there,
both states, they're typically going to be
left.
Trump didn't win New York.
He didn't win California.
They're liberal states.
And there's a lot of millionaires in those
states.
Now how is that even possible?
Well, being a millionaire or a billionaire
or rich doesn't necessarily mean you have
to become a Republican.
They economically believe in capitalism.
They don't believe in communism.
They believe in capitalism.
But socially they believe in other things,
pro-choice, they may believe in certain things
that conservatives may not believe in.
But just because someone's rich doesn't make
them a Republican.
#10: They're narcissistic.
All they want to do is look themselves in
the mirror and just say, "I'm so pretty.
I'm so amazing.
I'm so beautiful.
They're narcissistic.
They have problems with how much they admire
themselves.
One thing I noticed is typically, somebody
who lacks confidence, they don't like people
with a lot of confidence, even though secretly
they admire them because it's like, how can
somebody, they must be narcissistic.
Now this is not everybody.
I'm not putting a blanket over everybody.
But what I am telling you is, somebody who's
extremely confident doesn't necessarily mean
they're narcissistic.
It's a strength.
They believe in themselves.
I wish everybody believed in themselves more.
If everybody believe in themselves more, they're
going to do better in their lives.
Believe me.
Half the struggle is to make people believe
that they can pull it off in their lives as
well.
That is half the struggle.
That's what they've got going on.
It doesn't necessarily mean they're all narcissistic.
Are there some narcissistic ones out there?
Of course.
#11: Next, shhh, they don't pay their taxes.
They don't pay their taxes.
Paul, I'm going to do a basic mathematical
formula here so we can actually look at it,
so you can see for yourself how this number
works.
Last year America, the government collected
roughly three and a half trillion dollars
in federal income taxes, okay?
Now, let's set that aside for three and a
half trillion dollars.
Today in America, there's 158 million people
in total workforce.
There's 158 million people that work in America.
The average salary is roughly $36,000. $36,000,
158 million people working.
And let's say on average people pay 25% in
taxes, which is $9,000.
So if we take $9,000, and multiply it times
the 158, we get roughly 1.4 trillion dollars.
Okay?
That's how much the government collected last
year, 1.4 trillion dollars.
If it was only collecting the money from people
that make $36,000 per year.
Now watch this.
you take 1.4 trillion but we collected three
and a half trillion.
Where's the other 2.1 trillion dollars?
Where did that come from?
That's because the high income earners who
make millions of dollars pay a lot of taxes.
They pay a LOT of taxes.
Yes, there are some ways where they figure
out ways to pay less taxes because somebody
in the government they voted for changed certain
laws that they pay less taxes.
That's simply why it is.
They can change it if they wanted to, but
those loopholes are in, because somebody funded
someone's campaign 10, 20, 30, 40 years ago.
This is what happens, right?
But regardless, they still pay their taxes.
But Pat, you don't understand, Trump didn't
pay his taxes.
Let's just say Trump doesn't pay taxes.
Of course Trump pays his taxes.
But let's just say that Trump doesn't pay
his taxes.
Let's just say he doesn't.
That's not everybody, if he didn't.
And I'm not even saying that he didn't pay
his taxes.
The point is, everyone's paying their taxes.
How much, they're even paying more than a
lot of people are paying.
#12: And last but not least is they party.
All they do is they want to party, they're
these extroverts, they're very good with people
and they just want to go out there and they
got these big personalities, all this other
stuff.
Could it be some?
Sure.
A lot of the people that I meet who are very
well off, a lot of the people that I meet
who are very well off, believe it or not,
they actually kind of are the nicest people
I meet.
They're such nice people.
And they want to be around their kids.
They want to be around their family.
They want to have their vacations.
There's this one man that he's also in the
insurance industry.
You know, for 35 years, look at this here.
For 35 years, he has one tradition.
Every single year for two weeks, he pays for
his entire family and he takes them on a cruise.
He's done this for 35 years.
Think about that.
Two weeks.
They go on a cruise.
And the kids pick where they want to go.
I said, "How many were at this last one?"
He said, "35 people were at this last one."
What do you pay for it?
He said, "Pat, I pay for everything.
Flight, room, food, everything.
They pay for nothing.
He does this every year.
He wants his family to be around.
He said, "To me, if I could do everything,
in all the time I have, I want to be around
my family."
The extravagant, all that other stuff could
be a Hollywood type of a lifestyle, but it's
not everybody.
So having said that, again, my pure outcome
of this video is, I hear this so many times,
Pat, I don't want to be rich because rich
people are greedy and all they care about
is themselves.
Or I grew up with this myself, this mindset,
and all this other stuff.
I want to talk about this because many people
have requested on talking about this issue.
And I got a book recommendation for you as
well.
Paul, let's put a picture of it up so everybody
can see.
This is a book by T. Harv Eker.
It's called Secrets of the Millionaire Mind.
I highly recommend it.
It's exceptional.
It's phenomenal, everybody ought to read it.
It will make you think about millionaires
and money in a completely different way.
Paul, let's get the pillow here.
That was a good catch.
You like that catch?
It's a one-handed catch right there.
Phenomenal throw.
Paul, you got a little bit of Tom Brady in
you.
Alright, so here we go.
Hey, our goal is to get to a million subs
by the end of the year.
If you haven't subscribed, click on the button.
If you've already subscribed but you don't
get notifications, click on the alert right
next to it so you get alerted every time a
new video gets uploaded, you'll be one of
the first who gets it.
And at a quarter million subs, we're doing
a new contest to do something where people
will fly in.
Last time we did it it was a big hit.
People flew in from seven different countries.
We went hours over here, questioning, all
this other stuff.
It was phenomenal.
And we will do it again at a quarter million
subs.
I think right now we're at what?
196,000 subs?
197,000 subs, while recording this video.
So if you haven't subscribed, do subscribe.
If you got any comments or questions about
today's video, comment on the bottom.
With that being said, thanks for watching
everybody.
Take care, bye bye.